- [Instructor] For many hundreds of years,
mathematicians have been fascinated
by the infinite sum, which
we would call a series,
of one plus 1/2 plus 1/3 plus 1/4,
and you just keep adding
on and on and on forever.
And this is interesting on many layers.
One, it just feels like something
that would be interesting to explore.
It's one over one plus one
over two plus one over three,
that each of these terms are
getting smaller and smaller.
They're approaching zero,
but when you add them all together,
these infinite number of terms,
do you get a finite number
or does it diverge, do
not get a finite number?
This also shows up in music
and this actually might have been one
of the early motivations
for studying this series.
Where if you have a fundamental note,
a fundamental frequency in music,
and the point of this video
isn't to teach you too much
about music, but if you
have a fundamental note,
that might be a pure A
or something like that.
I'm just showing you
one of its wavelengths.
Obviously, you would keep going like that
and hit is a hand-drawn
version, so it's not perfect.
The harmonics are the
frequencies, the overtones,
that at least to our
ear, reinforce that A,
and what's true about the harmonics are
that they will be 1/2
of the wavelength of A.
In which case, it might
look something like this.
So this would be a harmonic of A.
It has half of the
wavelength of A and notice,
it gets, when it finishes
its second full wave form,
it ends again right at the same time
that the wavelength of A ends.
And then it would be another harmonic
where it'd be something that
has 1/3 the wavelength of an A
and a 1/4 of a wavelength of A,
and if you look at a lot
of musical instruments
or what sounds good to our ears,
they're playing not
just a fundamental tone,
but a lot of the harmonics.
But anyway, that was a long-winded way
of justifying why this is
called the harmonic series.
Harmonic, harmonic series.
And in a future video,
we will prove that, and I don't
want to ruin the punchline,
but this actually diverges,
and I will come up with general rules
for when things that look like this
might converge or diverge,
but the harmonic series
in particular diverges.
So if we were to write it,
so in sigma form,
we would write it like this.
We're going from n equals one
to infinity of one over n.
Now another interesting thing
is well, what if we were to
throw in some exponents here?
So we already said, and
I'll just rewrite it.
Doesn't hurt to rewrite it
and get more familiar with it.
This right over here
is the harmonic series.
One over one, which is just one
plus one over two plus one over three,
so on and so forth,
but what if we were to raise
each of these denominators
to say, the second power?
So you might have something
that looks like this,
where you have from n
equals one to infinity
of one over n to the second power.
Well, then it would look like this.
It'd be one over one
squared, which is one,
and we can just write
that first term as one,
plus one over two squared,
which would be 1/4,
plus one over three squared, which is 1/9,
and then you could go on and on forever.
Forever,
and then you could generalize it.
You could say hey, all right,
what if we wanted to have
a general class of series
that we were to describe like this?
Going from n equals one to infinity
of one over n to the p,
where p could be any exponent.
So for example,
well the way this would play out
is this would be one plus
one over two to the p
plus one over three to the p
plus one over four to the p,
and it doesn't just have
to be an integer value.
It could be, some, p could be 1/2,
in which case, you would have one
plus one over the square root of two
plus one of the square root of three.
This entire class of series
and of course, harmonic
series is a special case
where p is equal to one,
this is known as p series.
So these are known as p series
and I try to remember it
'cause it's p for the power
that you are raising this denominator to.
You could also view it
as you're raising the
whole expression to it
because one to any exponent
is still going to be one.
But I hinted a little bit
that maybe some of these converge
and some of these diverge,
and we're going to prove
it in future videos,
but the general principle is
if p is greater than one,
then we are going to converge.
And that makes sense intuitively
because that means that the
terms are getting smaller
and smaller fast enough
because the larger the
exponent for that denominator,
that means that the denominator's
going to get bigger faster
which means that the fraction
is going to get smaller faster
and if p is less than or equal to one,
and of course, when p is equal to one,
we're dealing with the
famous harmonic series,
that's a situation in which we diverge
and we will prove these
things in future videos.